[music playing]
NARRATOR: Hitachi
Province, Japan, 1803.
Local fishermen on
the Harayadori Shore
spot an unusual craft
drifting in the distance.
When the vessel washes
ashore, they are astonished
by what they witness.
NICK POPE: This craft
was likened to the shape
of a Japanese incense burner.
It is almost literally a
flying disk, a flying saucer.
On the outside of this craft
were multiple small metal
plates, not too dissimilar
to heat-resistant tiles
that you'd find, say,
on a space shuttle.
NICK REDFERN: A hatch opened,
and a young woman came out
of the craft dressed in clothes
that had never been seen
before, and speaking
a language that nobody
understood in the slightest.
DAVID CHILDRESS: When they
looked inside the craft,
they could see hieroglyphs
and strange writing
all inside of the craft.
NICK POPE: The story of the
strange Utsuro-bune craft
appears in three
different Japanese texts.
Even today, modern
historians struggle
to understand what this means.
Nobody can really decipher this.
DAVID CHILDRESS:
Japanese today are
very familiar with this
story, and to them, this
is a curious story of one of
the gods of their ancestry
who had somehow arrived
there on the island
in this mysterious
craft, and then departed.
NARRATOR: Could the
Utsuro-bune incident
have marked the return of
extraterrestrial beings
that were present in
Japan in the distant past?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and claim further evidence
can be found by examining
a strange monolithic stone
that many believe was carved
to resemble the very craft
that have been visiting
Japan for thousands of years.
Asuka Park, Japan, April, 2017.
Does that say rock ship?
Masuda rock ship.
Oh, all right.
NARRATOR: Giorgio Tsoukalos
and ancient astronaut theorist
Takeharu Mikami set out to
examine Masuda-no-Iwafune,
an 800-ton rock
structure that was carved
from a single piece of
granite, and resembles
no other architecture in Japan.
Hey, check out this
square grid on the sides.
I mean, this is something
that I've seen before
in India, in Mahabalipuram.
And they had
something very similar
on the side of some of
their rocks, as well.
I can't wait to see the top.
- Yeah.
[inaudible]
- Amazing.
Oh, man.
TAKEHARU MIKAMI: Whoa.
[japanese]
- Wow.
That is-- I mean, I've
never seen anything like it.
NARRATOR: While some
researchers believe
the Masuda-no-Iwafune
megalith is a tomb,
others claim it
is meant to depict
the sky boats that are described
in ancient Japanese stories.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: So the idea
is that this was the entrance
to a Buddhist temple.
What do they mean by that?
Inside-- I mean, where?
TAKEHARU MIKAMI: It would
actually predate Buddhism
in Japan, so it
wouldn't have anything
to do with Buddhist temples.
Right, so what is
the actual translation
of Masuda-no-Iwafune?
[speaking japanese]
Masuda is the
name of a region,
and Iwafune literally means
stone ship, or a rock ship.
OK.
MAN: [speaking japanese]
TAKEHARU MIKAMI: Yes.
It's naturally the
Iwafune or the rock ship
would have come down
from the heavens
as a vehicle for the gods
to descend upon earth.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: So I
guess with the combination
of those mythologies
of celestial beings,
this could be some type
of representation of one
of those flying vehicles
that our ancestors
perhaps witnessed.